this is a production of cornell
university
all right everybody uh thanks for
joining for another episode of our
cornell turf show this is episode four
this year um
as always my name is carl scamenti i'm
joined by dr frank rossi
frank you always have some opening
remarks for us so i'll let you get those
ready um and we hope to have our guest
evan mesquitti
uh on from penn state uh here this
morning um tbd so we'll see if that uh
if he he's able to make it but um
let's let's get into it frank let's see
what you're what you're thinking about
these days early season weather is
obviously the
the sort of big topic everybody's
talking about here no doubt carl and and
welcome everyone uh you know to our
first sports session right this is what
episode four
as we count them but it's the first time
we're gathering as a sports group
uh and you know for me
i'm a baseball guy i think there's three
of us left now with the stupid way
baseball runs itself these days but um
i'm very excited for this and one of the
things that
i think i'm getting a little sick and
tired of talking about dead grass with
golf course superintendents and i feel
horrible
for these folks that have a lot of dead
grass there and the grass you know i
don't know if anybody noticed but it's
still march
and
anybody in northern climates knows march
could be 8 degrees or it could be 80
degrees
and i think
it is hard uh i i would encourage you to
not get too worked up about anything
because you're going to see a pretty big
fluctuation over the next couple of
weeks i think the long-term couple week
outlook is looking a little good for
warming up but it's not looking like
that moving forward so carl is a old
picture at the 2009 opening day yankee
stadium and and shout out to the new
member of our cornell team uh chris
sitko back when he was banging his head
must have banged that one too many times
now he's back here uh from the vineyard
golf club as the director of our golf
and sports turf management operation
here at cornell and and i was in new
england a couple weeks ago talking about
the work we've been doing with our
division 1 soccer players but actually
the conversation today is baseball
before we get to that carl the classic
line is we care about what happens
between the lines and it looks like
that's your data for today
yeah and one of the things you know you
mentioned chris cinco there back when he
was doing our grad graduate work here at
cornell
uh we did kind of an audit of of the
athletic field management and and just
seeing how many hours it took to line
the fields and an operation at cornell
where there's some playing fields three
high quality playing fields a bunch of
auxiliary fields that uh intramural
sports use things like that uh quite a
lot of time that that's taking up
painting the fields and
uh the other day i heard about putting
primo a growth regulator in the paint
just to make it last longer and extend
some of the
uh intervals between when you have to
line out pain so i was interested okay
is there any data out there
and it turns out there is this is data
from uh down south in kansas and florida
so warm season grasses but gives us a
good indication of maybe how much we can
stretch out some lining intervals if we
throw some
premo's the growth regulator used
trenexa pack ethyl as the active
ingredient
and it actually changes based on the
paint type based on what they found so
white paint you can add something like
five days to your interval uh keeping
the quality as opposed to just normal
paint red paint you can extend it even
further seven days
so for our golf course superintendents
lining out lateral hazards that's maybe
something you're interested in
but they didn't see too much extension
in the interval with yellow paint but
just an interesting thing if you add
that up over the course of the year and
the shoulders of the season when the
turf isn't growing so much you might see
those intervals extended
and with cool season grasses maybe that
aren't growing as much compared to warm
season grasses getting going
in the summer uh we might find some some
efficiencies there so just to keep in
mind that's an option
something i hadn't heard about until
recently and an interesting data to look
at if you're
carl you are correct uh when we audited
the fields they're doing a lot of time
painting lines i don't think anybody who
takes care of sports fields won't agree
uh with painting lines except greg
elliott he still uses powder out in san
francisco at oracle park uh he's still
using uh
the cal line uh for batter's boxes and
lines down the thing you just don't see
that very often okay so for the sports
guys how about a little weather review
uh no surprise that the average
temperature uh from september to
november to early part of the fall
season when we had sports probably was
pretty good for us
because we were getting warm
temperatures later into the season and
the activity on the at least when the
grass is growing the plants can recover
and one of the great things is
particularly if you need traffic
tolerance in the fall is the very high
minimum temperatures in fact record high
minimum temperatures that we received in
the northeast is the warmest september
to november minimum temperatures we've
ever had now december stayed and kept
that warm period again minimum warm
temperatures and we're starting to think
maybe this might have something to do
with hardening off and maybe if you're
having some trouble with some recovery
this might be it
but then by january the minimums were
getting colder and we were a little bit
below normal for the month of january
and this could be where maybe some cool
season grasses got set back but it
warmed up pretty quickly again this time
shifting to the maximum temperatures and
seeing that the maximum temperatures uh
went up pretty good after that now as we
start to think about taking care of our
sports fields in the spring you know
obviously you need temperature for
growth and we're going to talk about
that in a second but going into the
winter the problem with the fall season
was also that it was among the wettest
right you look at central new york you
look at the the mohawk valley uh the
leather stocking region up there around
albany you see a lot a lot of moisture
and you see out on the cape on a mass
out on the western end at all western
mass out there pretty wet out there
and again looking at normal precip
departure from normal precip you see
we're at 200 percent normal
since december
so not only was it wet going in for a
lot of us but it's been wet coming out
right however it still has left a few of
us on the dry side
right uh you get down into philly
southern new jersey the northern reaches
and i didn't
i was a little lazy this morning i
didn't get the updated drought map uh
for this coming week
and and some of this might be relieved
uh in the moving forward now again we've
been pretty warm the temperature
departure up into the last few days was
10 to 12 degrees above normal unless
you're right along the coastal areas you
see those coastal areas they're not
getting
as warm as inland areas or get it
so the but here's the story right we're
going to be wet up along the coast where
they need the moisture uh you're going
to get a fair amount of it one to two
inches moving forward for the weekend
so again if you're out there with people
you know soccer camp starting and you
know school games starting uh they're
gonna be playing on on wet fields
now the other thing to keep in mind is
the forecast moving forward is is not
looking good for warm temperatures
you're looking at max's in some places
in the 30s and 40s
and barely reaching into the 50s uh even
along the coast
so just to put this in perspective right
what did what does this temperature mean
from how the grass grows well the
one of the tools we use to talk about
this nowadays is something we call
growth potential it is basically the
temperatures by which under which
photosynthetic activity the reaction in
the plant that turns chemical light
energy into chemical energy
and how efficient that is
under certain temperatures so if you
look at where the average temperature
could make it to 50 degrees let's say
your average temperatures were 50
degrees and you're feeling like oh i'm
working in shirt solutes that grass is
only at about 25
growth potential which means
you're wearing it it's not growing
backway that quickly because it's only
at 25
right imagine you didn't get a good
night's sleep
and you only got a couple hours
you only got about 25 energy for that
day you feel like pretty good about a
12-hour day i don't think so so let's be
really careful and be mindful of the
fact that the grasses really aren't
getting going
except in some problem areas in fact
they get going in compacted in wet areas
even faster
but long term they're more likely to
fail
now the forecast isn't looking good if
you think about 50 as a base temperature
by which things have to get over to
start accumulating heat and getting our
systems going right you can see we're
not expecting a lot of base 50 growing
degree days single digit
base 50 growing degree days for the next
several days
and again if you're trying to get things
going we're talking about this with golf
course superintendents if you're getting
cloudy weather like this is a map of the
sky cover for yesterday if you're
getting cloudy weather
you're not able to draw heat panty you
don't have that star in the sky beating
down
on your areas that might be darker
getting them going if you don't have if
you have cloud cover so you got to have
sun to get these systems going
okay so
here's our soil temperatures they're
moving into the 50s just remember your
roots are actively growing when your
soil is not frozen so if you've got
plants there they're getting themselves
stabilized for the traffic they're going
to experience right so so it's not like
necessarily you're not getting the
routing that you need right and if you
got some late routing from last year you
probably are seeing some benefits of
that but you're not getting top growth
right you're simply not getting topical
so if you're coming out of the winter
looking like this on your sports field
and not only is this a bad picture it's
a bad picture of a bad feel
right and for those of you listening on
the podcast i feel bad but you can
imagine close your eyes and imagine the
worst looking spring field you can't
imagine especially right down the middle
where the traffic gets focused on any of
these fields
and one of our great fans of the show
who will be a guest with us carl in a
couple of weeks ben palmer
uh was tweeting out not long ago about
waking up in the spring looking at soil
temperatures getting the feet you know
looking at the color of the fields
getting the skin ready trying to do some
practices to be sure that the fields are
ready to start receiving traffic in the
spring so a lot of good information
about important spring startup
activities and we'll certainly talk more
about this with ben moving forward right
so so here's what's going to start
happening
everybody's playing lacrosse going to
start getting out there this sport i got
to tell you i didn't know anything a lot
about this sport until about 20 years
ago i actually think this is the worst
sport for traffic because of how the
traffic gets focused
around that goal mount than a lot of
stuff that happens now nobody's looking
at this but you zoom in
and one of the things we start to
realize when we look at our fields
through a lens of safety
right when we're looking at them through
a lens of safety
one of the things that we know is
inconsistencies in the field surface and
you can see what are you looking at here
you're looking at a little bit of bare
ground you can see some dirt let me get
my pen carl i think i can do this in my
pen so you see you're looking at some
bare dirt but you're also looking at
some clumps
right you got clumps you got it divots
right and you can see all these
imperfections
in the field and just to go back up
so you can see maybe they're stepping on
good ground now but they're looking up
playing not looking down and we've
learned about this from gerald and from
uh chase gerald henry professor henry
down in georgia and chase droves now in
texas uh
about how players can sense these
imperfections and why we're trying to
get smarter about this uh moving forward
all right so let's get back to the
temperature and how the grass is not
going to be growing when it gets beat up
well the first thing you better do
is start talking to people now listen
everybody sucks at this i suck at this
and i know i got to be good at it
sometimes sometimes i'm a little too
direct with these people although we're
all busy and don't have a lot of time
you got to massage it a little bit when
you're talking to coaches and
administrators and understand the
language that they're taught right
they're talking the language of
liability they're talking the language
of they got parents screaming at that
they're talking the language of
budgetary constrictions they're talking
the language of here well why can't you
get this done right so it's important to
have an ongoing conversation with your
coaches and administrators and
especially when these early fall springs
start to happen right we're about to
experience our full first fall spring
temperatures in the 50s and 60s for the
last several weeks right
enjoying them every once in a while and
now teens are coming uh to some places
in the far northern reaches of these
areas right
so
what should you be considering on sports
fields well me
if i had lacrosse i tried to get a
blanket and i put it over those areas
when they weren't using it or if they
really wanted a nice gold mouth for
their game i'd say i'm covering this you
go put the gold mount in fact if you
look closely at this picture you can see
them painting different gold mounts in
this image right look look at how
they're painting
the different goal mouse in this image
just to move the traffic around right
just to move the traffic around so
target cover areas to draw in some heat
and get them going and this is nothing
but a function of getting heat to that
system well listen it's springtime and
as we said we've been really excited
about baseball we're so thrilled to have
uh our partner here that we've talked
about before having muscati bischetti
muskini which is a machete actually just
like the knife machete very good
so we got a rossi a scamenty and a
machete yeah very very italian american
webinar all right so we're talking skin
care but not that kind of skin care and
when i'm talking skin care i'm trying to
think about safety evan when we do this
and so i like to talk i'd like to get
your thoughts about this one of the
first things that comes to my mind is
lips
right this tends to be a real thing that
even like literally you know backyard
fields you probably want to spend the
time doing this because that ball is
going to interact at the edge talk a
little bit about the way you think about
lip preparation in the spring
yeah definitely spring is is really the
best time to do that first hard edge
when i say hard edge what comes to mind
is this upper right photo that you have
with the lupo or hula hoe
obviously you have some growth during
the winter time not a lot but then you
also have material migrating into the
into that interface and there's two
concerns obviously the safety as you
mentioned for ball bounce but certainly
for drainage too and especially along
the back arc of the infield
a lot of times you end up with that sort
of smiley face i call it where you have
a puddle or a ring of water along the
back arc
and that sort of gets to be a
self-defeating cycle because the more
that more material washes in there you
know the more that soil is going to
settle down as i think you and your
buddy or your mentor marty petrovic did
a lot of work on sediment runoff right
and grass is one of the best sediment
traps that there is and so as that
material migrates towards the back
once it hits the turf it's not going
anywhere it's going to sink and melt so
yeah i mean i think these all four of
these photos are are acceptable ways to
attack this problem um definitely
depends on the scope of the the size of
the lip that you have and ideally you
can take care of most of these things in
the fall when things are dryer
but definitely to clean things up um
this sort of maintenance or first hard
edge where you're going really past the
thatched layer just into the soil a
little bit like you have with the circle
there but if it is more severe
um obviously the hula hoe or the the
manual approach isn't going to be
sufficient and so you have to resort to
something like this sod cutter that you
have in the top top left um i really
pity anybody who's using this manual saw
cutter in the bottom i mean that it
could work but you're going to be uh
you'll be working your muscles for sure
and then obviously in an extreme case
this combinator or they're even
like the turf planer or the there's like
a laser guided machine that will
actually take off that whole lip and
that's
you know if you have a couple inches of
lip buildup this is really the best way
to go because it's fast and it's super
accurate so it really depends on the
scale of what how much material you need
to remove okay so now let's say i did
this even at the smallest level here the
grass has moved in
i i've got to put some material back in
there right yeah
grass grown into the clay or has the
clay washed into the grass you're saying
on the ark side the dirt's washing into
the grass
is this side where the grass is growing
into the shade
into the skin
yeah it can be some of both and
definitely um with i think most of the
listeners here attendees here are in the
north so you're not dealing with bermuda
grass which tends to be a little more
aggressive and stolens and whatnot but
absolutely the bluegrass can migrate
into the clay also um and so
if you want to measure this off it's a
good time to reset make sure
everything's straight too um i think
i've got a little off your original
question but the answer is yes the grass
can grow both into the clay and you got
to get material back oh in the back yeah
so for sure so this is backfilling is
one of the most misunderstood parts in
my opinion of edges um
because you can't just leave this the
way it is obviously you've created this
channel now by removing you want to go
down deep enough to get the roots and
the rhizomes out of there
but you can't just fill this with
conditioner either or whatever the loose
material is on the top so this is almost
like repairing a mound where you want to
have a sharp tool to actually scarify
the clay or you know we use the term
play loosely right but the the infield
max or the fine textured base oil that
you have there
um you know this time of year a lot you
do have good decent moisture actually a
lot of times as long as it's firm enough
to get out there so that new material
will bind or pack but this is something
you do want to take your time with and
if you have the ability you don't hit
this once with a hand tamp to really get
it compacted or if you're doing multiple
fields you may not have the time to do
that you got to be a little more
efficient and you can just tire roll it
but a lot of times this is two lifts of
material and you're basically scarifying
it and clean just like you would a
pitcher's mount to get that nice firm
surface instead of just filling that
trench with conditioner so yeah
absolutely backfilling is really
important yeah this is excellent so now
we got you right so you told us last
year oh boy great article right the
cleat in cleat out the way to deal with
the ball bounce you know how the surface
is going to have a different response
when it chunks up and clocks up so we're
just reminding everybody we did a show
with you about this and here you are
back when you were working now you're
sitting in a lab most of the time uh
doing all kinds of crazy stuff here's
that article that you draw us to and
then you know evan i don't know how much
you were involved in this but i gotta
say you couldn't have been very much
involved because they squeezed this
thing in this document and you know i
know nicole was happily heavily involved
in this nicole sherry from the orioles
and the infield thing is in the early
chapter squeezed in here a little bit
right uh and we're gonna get into this
but this is where we begin to see and
people can go to this publication and
see some of these best management
practices and begin to understand as you
said the nature of this material and
that's what i'm going to drill in with
you uh as we move forward here let me
get my slides moving now in the best
management practices right right in the
best management practices is this storm
water management right so i got my old
pal paul zwaska's got a bunch of these
groundskeeper university things paul's a
wisconsin guy i know him from 30 years
ago and he's got this suction pillow so
let's start here you like this thing or
are you a conditioner man or both so
let's take a minute
and have you work us through
how you approach uh you know these wet
infields before we get to uh your clay
how do we get after this now
yeah so there's a couple of qualifiers
there's two two things before we talk
about the fixing the
situation which is urgent and needs to
be fixed but number one never forget
that you want to fix the real problem
here which is that you have a low spot
on your infield right and that's not
going to be fixed today there's there's
no getting around that you want today
you want to get the game in but
ultimately this this field needs to be
regraded we need to have material
imported and probably tilled and uh this
looks like a pretty large low spot
bigger than you could fix maybe with
hand tools so that's the number one
thing is you want to always encourage
positive surface drainage and that's
part of that is having the right
materials and whatnot so that's
qualifier number one qualifier number
two is you want to try to stay off of
this as long as you can um paul's you
can see you can see he's making just
some minor footprints to get out there
this is okay but this is kind of
borderline because if you see material
squishing out from underneath your shoes
just by walking out there you create
more of a mess that you already have and
it's gonna be more work later on so with
those two things said
um yes number one thing is to remove the
surface water
in as least with as least amount of
disturbance as possible so the sponges
work really well you can even use old
couch cushions if you have an old shop
couch you know that you're looking to
get rid of before you fork forklift that
thing into a dumpster take the cushions
off
and you can use them to squeegee water
or to squeeze it up and you know put it
in a bucket or something another thing
you can do if you have a larger area
like this you might dig a small hole you
know maybe the size of a coffee can to
sort of concentrate that water and you
can pump it out and there's there's
manual pumps or or ones that you can run
off that generator or something so
that's two ways um you want to try to
remove the water that's on the top
before it gets into the skin once it
gets into the in and penetrates into the
profile it's a little more difficult to
remove now this is a great image
i'm assuming you probably took this as a
screen grab so that's it i did he has
this wonderful youtube series called
ground keeper u yeah like i said i've
known paul a long time i'm putting him
up here because i think he's got chops i
think he knows what he's talking about
he does he does actually paul was my
first boss he gave me my first
groundskeeping job when i was when i was
18 years old at this facility at west
mass little league no so
yeah it's a small world
but no the groundskeeper you thing is is
awesome he worked really hard on that so
these are these are the two sort of
gradations and so to speak of of calcine
clay you know they're baked in a kiln to
to make them hard particles so this is
different than
clay in the traditional sense right so
these granules are going to be firmer
but
um you know you try to avoid using the
finer gradation because this works into
the skin very easily and you tend to get
this kind of gummy consistency if it's
not removed so in an emergency
that will soak up even more moisture
than the larger uh calisthenic like
granules but it's something you want to
try to remove after after the game so
that doesn't get incorporated into the
profile now on the left this sort of
coarser gradation almost like a i guess
would be fine gravel in terms of
particle size
now that that can stay out there and be
used as a top dressing and not only will
it wick up a little bit of extra
moisture but it provides a nice sliding
surface and um makes it feel a little
bit more groomable right so the players
can even fix little indentations with
their cleats themselves so that's two
ways soaking up the extra water
obviously to get the free free water
away first but then to get a little bit
more of a buffer and to absorb some of
the free moisture these two products
will both work okay so
to the material
your latest article last october
you're going crazy young man you have
gone into the deep dive on this
particular topic and you drew you sucked
me in with you i think you presented
this at a crop science meeting i think
you did it at sfma
where now you're starting to propose us
thinking about clay
not as a substance but as a behavior
right the behavior of the material and
you went through in this article that
we'll commend to everybody to look at
looks like you spend your time making
clay uh
blocks here as well
but you really got me when you talked
about professor casagrande and his work
in the 40s developing runways
out in the pacific islands to land
bombers on now this probably wasn't the
tool he was using maybe because you said
it was a simple tool that they were able
to develop
this is the casa grande bowl was this it
that's it so he he it's named after him
um yeah he's a fellow ivy league guy
like yourself and uh that system that he
came up with
is still used today so he you know the
original test was atterberg um
this guy in sweden he actually had
basically just a bowl and he put the
soil paste in this cup and he would just
smack it on his hand and casa grande and
tarzagi who is his mentor they basically
decided look this is a cool test but
it's not standardized we need to make
this mechanized and so that was the
apparatus and it's undergone a couple
modifications but basically it comes
down to us today as it was almost 100
years ago
so what am i looking at here you've got
in this article you go from the various
ways making a pencil
to crumbles to the liquid right and then
you tweeted out this picture with your
uh cake things that you made
and then you have this chart but what i
know you're trying to do
is figure out what are the standardized
methods for testing some of these things
that we can then give people information
about the way they'll behave
so
let's start with
is this a place to start or do you want
to start with that it's 30 clay 30 sand
how did the modern infield systems
behave because you know fundamentally we
we want these guys
to you know not everybody's got
great uh
clays they can't cover it
right are you gonna get us to the point
where you can say listen if you don't
have a covered field you got positive
drainage here's the kind of material you
need if you're going to cover it here's
the kind of material you need is that
what you're heading to and is this a
graph of something that's going to help
us understand that
yeah yeah there's lots of impact so that
the covering versus not covering is
definitely a component um and in general
if you're not able to manage the
moisture
having a soil that is hot what i call
higher plastic or what it's called in
geotechnical engineering a higher
plastic soil that's not a good idea
because these soils their behavior is
highly dependent on the water content
and so
while they can accept more moisture
before they become liquefied
when they dry out they become very very
hard and very difficult to manage and so
a soil that might
fall in the top right of this diagram a
high plastic clay
said they tend to have more shrinkage
they tend to be really stiff and very
difficult to work with tools once they
dry out so those those kind of plays um
like the tournaments often used in
baseball is like a gumbo clay which is
sort of informal but so that kind of
clay um can perform really well but it's
not for beginners right it requires a
lot of a lot of maintenance and always
being covered so with this just to back
up a little bit what this chart is
it's a completely different way to think
about classifying solving play
and
this is sort of the the
the pepsi
uh this is sort of like like the
geotechnical engineers pepsi to the soil
scientist coke right if we have the
textural triangle that would be the
primary way that we classify soils on a
physical property basis um at least at
first blush and this is a similar
concept but
it doesn't rely on particle science so
the words clay and silt if you think
back to that you had that other diagram
where we had drawn the large uh sand
particle and then the finer sand and
then silt clay right so these are the
particle size definitions and this is
it's so intuitive it's hard to get
people to rip their minds away from
thinking about this as particle science
but geotechnical engineers they don't
even use this concept at all for
distinguishing between silk clay they
don't they don't care what's in it they
care they don't care
no they care what it behaves and so the
words silt and play they don't those
they don't have a particle size
connotation this is how they distinguish
between them and um
so that's what this chart represents
and
you this is it's meant for fine-grained
soils but you can use this uh sort of
off-label to classify infield mixes too
which have a blend of sand and clay
technically those soils they're they're
technically not really coarse grained or
fine green they're sort of like a hybrid
soil right so they wouldn't really fit
neatly into this classification scheme
that's that's sort of the broad concept
and so as you move generally from you
know bottom left to upper right
the soil is going to get more more
clay-like right so it's going to be
stiffer it's going to be harder it's
going to be more malleable or more
plastic which is what the word that we
use to describe the ability to be shaped
and molded and that's really the most
important trait of a of a mound or even
of an infield where you're looking for
that cleat and clean out playability the
soil to be sort of mold around the
cleats without breaking into pieces okay
so let's go back here because you talked
about the deformation when we were
chatting about paul walking on the dirt
here
this looks like clay that's behaving in
the liquefied state it's getting close
yeah yeah so it's it's able to flow
you're not quite under its own weight
but you have almost positive what we
call positive pore water pressure and so
when you step on that the load is born
more by the water than it is by the soil
skeleton
and water of course has no no shear
resistance whatsoever and this is where
if you think about safety number one
priority of of all you know sports
fields managers the safety is going to
be compromised because it doesn't offer
any shear resistance and so it'd be
pretty easy to slip okay so in that
article you did a deep dive in clay
platelets you're doing electron
micrograph stuff this is wonderful work
evan
what does it mean practically
again i was really appreciating you say
at the higher end these really good
materials
they're not for amateurs these are
things that like a putting green you got
to mow it every day
right
you're telling me this is dirt that is
going to get covered that's going to
have three or four guys to fuss around
with it on a routine basis usually guys
like you used to be that are taking care
of two acres of ground right
so
what are you telling the people that
zwask is trying to talk to
at the lower end about the way they
should be buying and looking at material
if they're looking at their stuff this
spring and saying listen i can't have
another spring like this i need to do
something to fix this what kind of
advice are you going to give these folks
to begin to look for materials that will
fit their needs
yeah the num i mean there's a couple
things one is your material needs to
have a higher sand content in general
because the sand is what allows that
soil to have more like friability i
would call it to be able to groom it
easily so that when you do get chunks or
clods or cleat marks whatever you want
to call them
that your drag can fragment them more
easily
those materials are not going to require
as much nail dragging they're a little
more forgiving
so generally you know to refer kind of
back to the original specification that
does work pretty well you want to shoot
for like 70 to 75 sand in that mix
and the other thing that we found and i
i don't i don't take credit for
discovering this but we've definitely
validated in our lab is that you want to
um you want a lot of that sand to be in
the coarser fraction so you want to
avoid the fine and very fine sands now
those terms are kind of relative but
as far as sizes go like anything below
0.25 millimeters you want to stay away
from and the reason is that material
tends to migrate really easily so that's
a significant challenge
on these kind of fields you're talking
about where there's not getting tarps
right so it's a huge difference because
when it rains that material can can wash
or migrate and this happens slowly
um but it does happen on every field no
matter how high maintenance it is and a
lot of times what will happen is the
material isn't even leaving the field
it's just moving from the top of the
crown down to the bottom
and you can sometimes rescue that but to
return the original question what to
look for in terms of the infield mix
that's one is the same content same size
and then consistency also so talk with
your supplier and find out you know how
are they blending the material is it
something that they
um can can produce repeatedly so that
next year when you buy another load is
it going to be the same product or is it
if it's something that's harvested you
know you don't know necessarily what the
the textural so so is this where a
product like dura edge comes in and this
isn't an ad for dura edge they're not
sponsoring anything but it is uh i know
mcna i know uh knight mcknight
uh when he developed it early on at
least working on it with danny uh yeah i
think they were playing around with it
years and years ago is that kind of
material a good choice for
the school grounds folks
yeah one thing that i like to tell
people when they're contemplating
installing uh like an engineered soil
like that is just if you have multiple
fields just try one field you know you
don't have to necessarily commit to
doing your whole complex and i don't
that can be difficult often to to
convince stakeholders but a lot of times
once you install something like that
that does perform better and doesn't
doesn't migrate as much
the difference is clear and you can you
can end up
saving money because you don't have to
cancel games right you have less you
have less uh revenue loss concessions
and things like that
so yeah i mean grant that's something
they really take pride in is their their
blending and quality control that they
can produce the same thing over and over
um and they're not the only company that
does you know quality control but
certainly they they have
become a very prominent member of the
industry for that reason is the infield
mix
inherently different from the batter's
box and the mounds and if it is in what
ways
yeah so this will go back to one of the
first slides you showed where i think
there was a specification on about under
30 sand and then there was like a salt
to clay ratio or whatever and so mound
mounds and plates are
so it could be you can build that out of
the same material as the rest of the
infield and at the absolute bare bone
maintenance level that's what i
recommend just leaving it the same
something you can just drag right over
right but
you need to have an understanding that
those the holes are going to be more
substantial and it's good it is going to
require a little bit more frequent um
repacking but the the process is simpler
than it would be to take care of
something that's higher clay content so
if you do install like clay bricks or
bagged clay that's a scenario where you
really need to commit them to keeping it
covered and having some water to prepare
so the materials themselves are they
tend to be different those mound clays
don't have sand added usually and they
are going to be stiffer and it's going
to provide better playability for the
hitter or the pitcher because the um
the material will stay in place and
it'll it'll withstand the wear over the
course of the game and i've watched i
mean i remember back in the day when
sabathia used to pitch for the yanks
when his leg came down he did talk about
chunking up it would cause other
pitchers so many problems they were like
hey get up
you got to fill this all right we're not
filling a hole it's not raining we're
not touching this thing that's your
problem so some of these guys some of
these mounds that material
i don't think people always realize the
amount of maintenance these things take
you got to go out there you got a big
guy pitching in your or big gal or
whatever even the women's softball
pitchers they can dig it up pretty good
as well um these holes can be really big
sometimes yes they can and this would be
one this is uh we can relate this back
to that plasticity chart where the
higher higher plastic clays tend to hold
up a little bit better because they are
stiffer and so though like a for a guy
like sebastian obviously that's he's a
big boy and so if you have a lower
plastic material or like an infill mix
that's going to really blow apart and
you can actually translate this even
down to a lower level though because
um although those materials tend to be
harder to work with and a little more
expensive you end up using less of them
right so when you scrape up the chunks
at the end of the day a lot of times the
hole will be smaller and so one thing
paul taught me is if you actually
go for the more expensive mountain play
you might end up saving yourself money
because you use less of it
so it's you know every every situation
is different but understanding the level
of where and your level of maintenance
is the number one thing how funny is
that you work for zwaska i had no idea
you worked for zwaska he we gotta gotta
get him to watch this and and we'll just
call it three italian guys talking about
dirt that's what we'll do here carl evan
thanks so much for taking the time it's
so great to have you i'm glad we got to
work this out carl why don't you get us
out of here
yeah thanks evan for joining um thanks
everyone guys appreciate it yep thanks
everyone for coming for another episode
of the cornell turf show i will see you
guys next week for another golf and lana
landscape show take care
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu